[Music]
james our producer came up with the idea
that we needed to do a greedy rich
people segment and periodically expose
these greedy horrible rich people
segment today we're going to pick on a
superstar yes
in the nba yeah
uh
bismack biambo yeah and i'm not an nba
guy obviously because i hesitated
pronouncing that don't tell me dave
ramsey doesn't prepare let's you should
just
yeah right
so
bismack uh apparently is one of these
gritty rich people because according to
this article on cnn uh he donated his
entire salary
from the nba
to build a hospital in his native
democratic republic of the congo
in africa
and honor his late father the phoenix
sun star the 29 year old returned to the
nba in january signing a contract for
the duration of the season and he
donated the entire amount 1.3 million
dollars to build a hospital
in his home country
and he uh he donned the 18 jersey for
the sons in honor of his father's june
18th birthday his father passed away
and he's donating the entire amount
to be named after francis
would
consolidate his legacy whilst helping
those in need back home i told my agent
my salary for this year will be going to
the construction of a hospital back home
to give hope to the hopeless
at home and those individuals that
cannot take their family members out
biambo said greedy rich guy yeah oh by
the way dave that 1.3 million donation
of a salary for the hospital is in
addition to the almost million dollars
worth of medical equipment that his
foundation uh sent over to the
democratic republic of congo in the
earliest of twenty twenty pretty rich
people do they usually double dip so
yeah so if you're gonna be greedy and
rich you should do it twice they have a
pattern of their greed yes this is
clearly a pattern out of control
generosity by these greedy rich people
it needs to stop you're giving bad name
to the greedy rich people when you're
generous like this that you need to stop
it yeah now here's what i'll also say
about how can that fit with the
narrative that's out there
well because here's what i mean well
he's messing it up he can't he's messing
up the narrative but this is the rare
situation dave you know this
um i'm not very wealthy at all but i do
know a lot of wealthy people here's what
i know they don't normally talk about
their charity and their donation this is
a story because he's in the nba but most
rich people you don't even know how much
they're giving you don't even know where
their fingerprints are because turns out
these awful greedy rich people don't
need credit either
oh they weren't doing they weren't
taking a poll it wasn't optics yeah no
they just do it oh
kind of like covet yeah yeah yeah it
wasn't about optics it wasn't about the
way it looked it's the way it actually
is yeah oh
that
i can't tell you how many rich people
that i've heard of and known that that
uh paid for supplies and private planes
and different countries all around the
world you never even see it on cnn but
it's happening it won't you you won't
because you won't find out about it and
it that'll be
reported i'm glad he reported this
because it exposed the greedy rich
people for what they really are yes and
i'm glad we have a news story i'm glad
cnn did their investigative journalism
and discovered that this guy is yet
another of those horrible successful
people
who are the best at their craft in the
world
and i chose to give the money away
and uh build a hospital i think it's
just horrible it's just awful you know i
can't believe people really do stuff
like that yeah this new generation worse
than that yeah he even talked about it
yeah and inspired other people to be
greedy rich people yeah it's just
horrible i can't believe it